most of time our next level of life
lives on the other side of our biggest
obstacle I wanted to be successful
because I hated not being in control of
my life as a kid I don't think we should
drive for money I think we should drive
to be a better version of ourselves need
motivation watch it's out 10 with
believe nation
what's that believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up in
poverty having a learning disability and
rebuilding cars as a mechanic to
becoming a highly successful real estate
entrepreneur and author he's Dean grad
COC and here's my take on his top ten
rules to success vol 2 joy
okay let's take it up with rule number
one change your story what stands
between us and where we want to go is
never what we think it is it's not the
economy it's not the president it's not
that somebody already dominated the
health food industry or dominated
Facebook advertising or dominated TV
advertising or there's no room left it's
never that it's always the story we tell
ourselves and why we can't achieve that
and and if I wanted to boil it down I
would just say what is your biggest why
what's your biggest goal that you would
love if it was a year from now and we
were sitting here you're watching this
and was a year later and it was the best
year of your life what would be the
biggest thing that would have changed in
your life from money income family love
intimacy being a better dad mom whatever
whatever that is if you say to yourself
I would love that goal like I'd love to
have my company doing a million dollars
a year in net profit so kind of freedom
for my family then just say but and
whatever that butt is is usually your
story it's like I would love my company
be doing a million dollars yet but I
live in a smaller town and there's just
not enough people do it or the
Internet's so saturated there's no room
to advertise on Facebook anymore cuz
every bringing their brothers on
whatever that story is is usually your
story and that's the results you get and
that story is the the thing the thing
standing between you and your next level
and and I know people are watching right
now gone Oh Dean that's nice you guys
got money now so it's easy I don't have
any money I don't have a partner I don't
have any business experience you know
this economy's not right for what we do
and and you know where there's where
there's you know that old saying where
there's a will there's a way
if that if your story is that that's
what you'll continue to get so what I
would say is if I was going to boil it
down is find what that story is
now to you you might be saying Dean
you're saying it's a belief it's reality
and maybe it's phase three but reality
is nothing more than our perception of a
situation right we all know that you've
read that in value of watching it on
Tom's show everybody had said it but
maybe is the first time you actually
think about it that that reality you
think is holding you back is really just
the story so there's two things I say is
go find somebody else with that same
story like go look at your your your
evolution where you were on your couch
no money right go look at Richard
Branson story look at Tony Robbins story
look at you know John Paul DeJoria or
all the amazing books everybod everybody
in there that's amazing the people
you've got the interview and me but read
all those stories and realize that first
of all that story you have is probably a
lie right so if you can find proof like
leverage that it's a lie that's one
thing but then the one that would get me
is I love aspiration I love to look and
say look what you did man III want to
get there he did it I can do it
but sometimes you need the pain as well
so what I like to do is I like to think
take that story and think it's five
years from now and think it's ten years
from now and you're still in the same
exact spot you are now you're still
worried you still have envy still want
more you desire more you want to take
care of your family you want to provide
more and think that that story those two
sentences is the thing holding you back
do you really want to give that story
that much power and then think it's ten
years from now and that story is still
done and all of a sudden it like for me
I think am I gonna let that story stop
me I brought my son with me today - stop
from giving him the opportunities that I
didn't I'm not raising I've two children
I'm not raising entitled kids I want to
give a massive opportunity I don't want
to leave him a trust fund I'm gonna
leave him massive opportunity and train
him I'm not gonna let any story get in
the way of me being that debt and if a
story pops up that says hey I can't make
baseball this week because of this I'll
change the damn story I'll fistfight
with that story and I'll look at the
pain I'll have if I keep that story so I
love the aspirational part of this story
will stop me from my new life but I also
like you let that story screw you around
for the next five 10 15 years I mean man
we're we're gonna be 90 laying in a bed
looking up like before we know it and
you want to think I squeezed all I could
out of life or did I let just beliefs
that other people gave me hold me back
rule number two put in the success tax I
love this phrase I've been saying about
six months success tax yeah you don't
worry love about that somebody told to
me I didn't make it up I found my own
version of it it's like we all want to
make more money we all
want to feel significance of abundance
freedom but most people aren't willing
to pay it so a great analogy I've been
using is if you're in a band and you
play the guitar you write songs it would
be amazing to be at Madison Square
Garden 50,000 people singing your song
you're out in the front of the stage I
mean could anything be more euphoric
right but everybody would want that but
who's willing to play the guitar when no
one's watching - your hands hurt who's
willing to pack up an old van that
barely runs and drive - dive bar after
dive bar playing where people are booing
you most people aren't willing to put in
the success tax to pay and I'd say I
said what if you just visualized what do
you believe in God whatever you believe
in that there's an auditor a success
auditor and you go okay ed ed started
which lives in a ghetto okay
but he's still positive every day Wow
he's still respectful Wow he tried that
first business and his first partner
screwed him over took all the money and
left while he still got up the next day
still inspiring other people still not a
jerk check check what if you got a check
off ten boxes before you get to the
other side because once you get to the
other side it opens up like Ed's amazing
backyard there's not many people playing
at that level like everybody thinks it's
so competitive up here it's not because
you guys are all fighting over crumbs
and I don't mean that disrespectfully
but all I'm saying is when you said like
putting the success packs and know
you're gonna fail no one's gonna go
sideways but it's worth it
rule number three burn the boats most of
the time in our life and I hate to say
this and maybe you've heard this before
maybe you know it to be true and if it's
first time in here I'm sorry to be the
one to share it with you most of time
our next level of life lives on the
other side of our biggest obstacle the
thing we worry about the thing we stress
about usually is the the little wall
that once we get past it through it
break a hole and on the other side is
our next level so with that in mind
think about that think of your next
level of life your income your business
your your success right you're on the
millionaires to success have its podcast
that means you want another level of
income life wealth abundance joy right
that's why you're here you'd be doing a
million other things you're with me and
I don't I don't take it lightly that's
why I want to deliver value but if
you're here that means what you want you
want that next level well if it lives on
the other side of the wall that's in
front of you the obstacles in front of
you if you have a plan B
in some cases that means you didn't burn
the boats you want to take the island
burn the boats so there's no other
choice but for tape but for taking the
island if you want to accomplish that a
conquer or accomplish that next level of
life goal abundance start that business
take your new your current business next
level finally stop listening to all the
naysayers tell your parents they're
crazy your friends they're crazy all
this the the BS that we have in life if
you want to do it a plan B will screw
you up because you got well if it
doesn't work I can go back when you get
to the wall and you start trying to
climb it I'm saying this wall is the
obstacle between you and your next level
of life obviously it's a metaphor but if
you get to the wall and you get a little
scratch on your hand you can go I can go
to plan B the boats are still in the
harbor maybe taking this Islands a
little too much no what I want to shock
you into thinking about today is if
you've been dabbling for so long if
you've been desiring a next level any
area in your life yeah this is the
millionaire success habits podcast but
any area of your life that you're not
having the breakthroughs you're not
having this success you want the next
level you want that means most likely
you have a comfortable plan v that's
good enough when you want to accomplish
something big something out of your
comfort zone that next level that you've
been craving then screw Plan B make
everything all of your energy plan a
burn the boats knock the wall down go
through the pain go through whatever it
takes and put all the focuses like no
there's no plan B this is this is my
life rule number four protect your
confidence I have this concept of
protect your confidence I've never heard
anybody say it like that before why is
that so important well because I think I
mean in all the big decisions you've had
to make along your way have you ever
made a good decision when your
confidence was down once like can you
say I walked in my head was down your
physiologies change you're like a little
nervous like you just don't make good
decisions when your confidence is down
and I don't think it's like we're either
confident or not confident I think it's
like if confidence is a hundred percent
if our confidence is ninety five percent
we play smaller I know with me like big
opportunities come if I'm not in that
like space I'm like you know what guys
let's just let's hold what's not like I
won't make smart decisions so I think I
think we have to do everything in our
power to protect our confidence rule
number five
find your drive what I have learned
through the years we all got in business
for different reasons yeah I wanted to
be successful because I hated not being
in control of my life as a kid my
parents were married nine times between
the two of them I moved 20 times nine
times so never stability you know get a
new house you got to leave go here leave
move in with Grandma so I think I hated
the insecurity of my childhood but it
was my driving force and thank you God
the universe whatever you believe in
thank you for that because it pushed me
to go hey I don't want I don't know
about you I know you and I hit it off in
the first three minutes we were talking
but I'm not a control freak but I don't
want anybody ever tell me how to live me
not address what where if I want to wear
orange sneakers today I'm gonna wear
orange sneakers I live where I want I
raise my kids the way I want I don't get
into peer pressure I don't hang out with
the Joneses or try to impress the
Joneses I just want to live my life but
I know that happened at a really young
age so backing up with your question is
that drove me so sometimes you need pain
to drive you and then you start being
successful then you can go to
aspirational now I want to be a better
dad be a better man be a better human
but if you need pain to drive you let it
drive you rule number six get rid of
negativity on your journey you're gonna
come across all new friends you're gonna
lose old friends for a while you're
gonna you're gonna get a people in your
life who love you that try to suppress
you and they're gonna want to hold you
back and here's the thing you have a
couple options in your life you can let
them dim your glow that you can let them
turn down your fire or you can realize
it's not their fault so let me just ask
you again I want to go back to this who
in your life makes you feel bad about
your dreams your goals your desires
because those people are affecting you
whether you realize it or not when you
have a desire for that next level
someone negative someone trying to
protect you tells you you shouldn't you
can't you might say now I'm not
listening to them but even if 5% of that
rubs off on you then you might make
different choices you might play a
little bit smaller than you need to your
confidence could be crushed just a
little bit more than it needs to be
crushed you know confidence is a weird
thing confidence doesn't go from zero to
a hundred in my eyes confidence if your
confidence is down 5% you're screwed
because you're gonna play small you're
gonna play safe do you think in today's
world you think being good at something
with moe
your confidence is enough do you think
being excellent with a 90% your
confidence is enough hell no you need to
be freaking outstanding you need to rock
it with your confidence at a hundred
percent and how can your confidence be
at a hundred percent if you're letting
people in your life make you dim your
glow to lower your expectations to play
safer rule number seven be the best
version of yourself I don't think we
should drive for money I think we should
drive to be a better version of
ourselves when money was no longer a
worry for me I drove into me and I've
been ignoring and tucking down a lot of
crap for a lot of years and I was
surface level I look like the guy that
had it all going on my businesses were
doing good I'm amazing children company
thriving I live in the right
neighborhood drive to like have the
right friends everything looked great
but it was all masked and when money got
out of the way I was able to find dig
into me and do my own personal
development and my own personal growth
and really find the things that I wanted
to fix so I could become a better
version because I know if I'm pointing
cuz my sons over there
it doesn't matter what I tell him as a
parent and if you're a parent you know
what I'm talking about I could teach him
everything I give him lessons we do
Sunday meetings I could teach him
lessons there he's gonna become Who I am
not what I say and I'm gonna lead by
example and I want to be a better
version of me and money's allowed that
money has not made me a
evil or done bad things it's it's
allowed me to not worry about that part
so I could focus on me and
simultaneously the more I focused on me
the more I wanted to take my money and
do better for other people I mean I
heard somebody say once when they said
they think money is evil I said you
haven't made enough and you haven't
given enough away yet to see that it's
not rule number eight be authentic I'm
trying to be the most authentic version
of myself that exists
like I don't ever want somebody and you
know this too how many times because
you've had amazing guests dude the
lineup you've had is incredible but
every once in a while it's not so good
to meet your heroes and I don't mean
like you know it's not that that you're
here on you idolize it you like man that
guy's a badass or that woman she's
incredible and then you're in the
kitchen with him for ten minutes like
wow like I don't ever want that I want
someone sneaking I saw Dean on video and
then I met him and then I saw him in a
tight situation and I saw him with his
kids all the same guy yeah and I think
that's where life like that's I just
want to be the same guy in all areas and
I think even though I'm working on
myself yeah it comes through on video
and my sales go up rule number nine find
excitement how many people do you know
maybe even you have a bad job that just
kills you it's draining your energy you
hate going there maybe even a company
that you started that you thought was
gonna be exciting but just it's just
robbing the life out of you or even
school maybe you're in college or even
high school and and it's just every
moment of it it's frustrating and here's
what we do we think to ourselves when I
get out of this job and I start my own
company Jan I'm gonna be fired up then
I'm gonna be excited then I'm gonna take
my life to the next level when I get out
of school I'm gonna do it when I when I
throw this company away and I start the
new company and guess what
that's the worst thinking that type of
thinking will keep you exactly where you
want so let me just give you an example
I don't know if you know this about me
but when I was in my teens and my
twenties I worked on cars every single
day of my life I had a collision repair
shop I I got wrecked cars and people
brought him in and I fixed them I sucked
fumes every day I had dirt under my
nails every night I was literally
scraping under my nails trying to get
piles of dirt out I changed motors I did
I rebuilt carburetors I mean the worst
thing I hated was painting the cars I've
got such a headache even though we had
good ventilation I'd get such a headache
from the fumes but that's what I did
then I loved painting cars no I
absolutely despised it I hated every bit
of it but I was lucky enough to realize
that how you do any job is how you do
every job and what I had to do was find
things that were exciting in that job
because I knew it
the stepping stone so here's what I
believe so many people hate what they do
their lack of energy when you don't like
something you're not enthusiastic you're
not excited you're not nice to people
so you're just thinking I'm gonna get in
this groove but then something's gonna
snap and then all of a sudden I'm gonna
be amazing I'm gonna be excited I'm
gonna I'm gonna find that new job that
new career know you have to start now so
what you have to do like I did with the
collision shop is you have to find a way
for that dull job that thing that Rob's
your energy now to be exciting yes you
do as hard as that sounds do it to the
best of your ability and guess what
opportunity comes along in places you
won't even realize that there isn't even
there's an opportunity for you let
example so I'm in the car business
hating it but I found a way to be
enthusiastic because what I liked is I
like the fact that a car would come in
wrecked I could visualize it looking
perfect again and visualize how excited
the person would be to get their car
back to me to new so when I was working
on cars I didn't think I got bondo and
my fingertips paint on my nails I got a
headache from the fumes I'm dirty it's
sweaty if I thought about that
everything would have sucked but what I
thought about was how excited the
person's gonna be when they see their
car back to normal and I found a way to
be enthusiastic and excited if you asked
anybody like that guy loves collision
work it's not true I wasn't lying I
found a way to manipulate myself so in
that instance my first big real estate
deal I did several with no money down
worked right my butt off to get it done
but my first big real estate deal that
after years was the first deal I did
over a million dollars on true story in
my little town in upstate New York
Town Hall Marlboro New York and guess
who I did the deal with somebody who
came into the collision shop and I did
work on their car lent me the money
because I was so enthusiastic so excited
such a good mood the guys like how do
you have so much energy how is so
excited I said well this is just a
stepping stone for me I'm working on
real estate deals I've done a few and
working on this bigger when he's like
well why aren't you doing the big one
I'm like I'm trying to put the money
together but I'll get it I know I'll
make it
that guy lent me $80,000 just like that
and he made a ton of money for it I mean
I I was so appreciative of the loan he
gave me I did everything in my power to
make sure that deal crushed it
I'm rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is understand
your worth I give you a million dollar
racehorse and it's this is the horse
that's got to run and win the Kentucky
Derby and win the Preakness or whatever
race it would be to make a lot of money
and you had a stable and you had this
horse how would you treat it would you
would you encourage the horse would you
pet it in a really nice way or just
smacking right would you be rude to it
would you give it love would you how
would you feed a million dollar
racehorse would you give it junk food
would you give it Fritos and soda and
feed it lots of beer and alcohol or do
you think you'd feed it like whole
grains if that's what a horse even I'm
not great with horses but if whatever
horse it would you find organic
gratefully there's a million dollar
racehorse now right this isn't just some
horse there's a million dollar racehorse
so would you feed it the best greens
organic take care of it here's another
thing would you would you help it get
good sleep or would you wake it up or
whoa and and not have it sleep good and
make it uncomfortable would you would
you want it to get its rest so it could
heal would you um would you let it just
sit in the barn or would you take it out
and exercise and keep it healthy now you
don't have to know anything about horses
I'm just saying I gave you a million
dollar racehorse how would you treat it
now I ask that question because that's a
horse and it's hypothetical and you're
probably like what the heck are you
talking about horses Dean I thought this
was the millionaire success habits
podcast and millionaires success habits
training when he's talking about of
horse for because we would I believe we
in so many cases would treat a
million-dollar racehorse better than we
treat ourselves you are your
million-dollar racehorse you are the
only one that can take you across the
finish line you are the only one that
wins the race we are gonna be left money
by an uncle or the government's gonna
just hand out tens of millions of
dollars to us for doing nothing
we're not gonna stumble upon an
invention by accident and become rich
overnight in most cases maybe hit the
lotto maybe have an uncle maybe a
stumble on an invention but in most
cases we got to find the grit we got to
find the determination we got to find
the passion we have to find the desire
to get out there and make it happen
true or false I mean is it true or false
so if you would treat a million-dollar
racehorse that way then why the hell
don't you treat yourself that way
now I've got a special bonus cup from
Dean on how to make your breakthrough
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what negativity do
you need to get rid of in your life
number two how do you need to better
protect your confidence and number three
what does being the best version of
yourself mean to you
I can remember being 15 years old and
feeling different than everybody in my
family like no one made money my dad I
had a really early age I equated that
hard work had nothing to do with success
my dad worked his ass off and he was
broker than what did dad do cars
collision shot wasn't and he worked hard
got up early paint under his nails six
some days from painting and fumes so I
realized that a really young age at
working hard had nothing to do with
being successful I had dyslexia I didn't
go past high school I barely got out of
high school and I knew I wasn't going to
college but I realized at a young age
that and somewhat being naive right
before the world told you know so many
times that I just I wanted to break out
of watching my parents struggle watching
all my family struggle again it doesn't
matter where you are if the the your
surroundings feel complacent if they
feel okay if they feel good and you want
amazing you know you got a breakthrough
and I was just lucky enough to just stay
persistent I wasn't afraid to fail I
didn't doubt myself even though I didn't
have the education the money
if you want more dean check out the
first top 10 rules video i made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
passion and from the heart always always
wins over over prepared and thinking
from the head